hey youtubers is Charlie so James gonna
drop the teaser for guardians of the
galaxy - in anticipation of Comic Con
next week so I'm gonna do a breakdown of
that but I'm also gonna explain why the
comic-con trailer they're releasing is
basically gonna be superb and all over
the internet so guardians of the galaxy
- is coming to Comic Con next week so
obviously an anticipation to that James
Gunn is just trying to build hype so he
released this teaser image with the team
like the new team and a couple extra
people now there's a whole bunch of
stuff going on in this picture but the
biggest thing is the actual look of
mansis in the film obviously she's gonna
be CG but this is probably pretty close
to what she's actually gonna look like
tell us about mantas man's played by tom
clemente f who is an amazing actress and
one of my favorite actors I've ever
worked with in my life
she's she's fantastic she's not green
obviously many of you people have seen
that she is more based on the original
design of mantas as opposed to the
retrofitted retconned mantas from later
does mantas have a huge role in this
movie yes she does she's kind of a deep
cut from the Guardians comic she comes
from annihilation conquest which in the
comics is kind of the story of how the
guardians come together it was part of a
bigger arc that involved Ultron and
space but they didn't really do that for
the movie like the first Guardians movie
took elements from that but mantis was a
Kree prisoner and she got swept up with
star-lord and his crew so she became a
guardian so that you know that's why
she's wearing this costume here but as
you can see here she's spritzing baby
Groot one of her special abilities is
the ability to speak to plants she has a
number of special powers I don't know if
they're gonna change that for the movie
James Dawn's only real teaser for mantis
is that her interaction with the
guardians is like her first interaction
with other people so she's going to
learn social skills from being with the
Guardians so you can imagine how that's
gonna lead to a lot of funny situations
like if you think that the guardians are
a good model of appropriate behavior but
baby Groot so James Gunn basically
confirmed that we're gonna see dancing
baby Groot for the duration of this film
he's like slightly bigger than he was in
the last film he kind of looks like the
toy that they released after the movie
came out so you can already see that
Marvel is capitalizing on something that
everybody loves
but James Gunn did
like he was like the question is though
is which version of Groot is he going to
be is he gonna be a regrown version of
the original Groot or is he like the son
of Groot so if you haven't read the
comics Groot regrows himself so he still
retains all of his knowledge so think of
it as like mr. sinister from the x-men
comics reconstituting his body from
blood or genetic material guru can do
that you just you have to like grow him
so it's gonna take time for him to get
big again but the word James Gunn used I
think was rambunctious he's gonna be
like a rambunctious little teenager
Groot so very clearly he's bait for
little kids so like if you have a little
brother or you have your own children
baby Groot is like their POV character
so the other big question that I saw a
bunch of you guys asking me was why
nebula is going to be a member of the
team I don't know necessarily that she's
actually going to be a legit member of
the team but it seems like she's gonna
be with them for at least a little while
because there's this Gamora and nebula
relationship that's gonna play out over
the course of the film they are sisters
they both been twisted by Thanos who's
kind of like their surrogate father so
just expect a lot of fun Gamora nebula
scene it's just you know sisters
treating each other just absolutely
terribly yondu and kragle and back of
course they made it sound like yondu is
gonna be a member of the guardians but i
don't know if that's necessarily the
case either do you know just like nebula
they might just be travelling with the
guardians for a little while so I guess
you could call them honorary members it
just depends on how specific you want to
get but cracklin is actually James
Gunn's younger brother mostly you
probably know him by now but they've
been teasing the Guardians comic-con
footage they're gonna be bringing there
will be Guardians footage can I give you
a hint a comic-con fun I think I've
given you guys a lot of hints at
comic-con fun I thought and you know
we're gonna show you something special
we're gonna be there and during the
Marvel panel which is the you know week
from Saturday Chris Pratt and I are
gonna be there we're gonna have a lot of
other people from the movie there so I
think it'll be really really fun I'm
excited to show you guys a little bit of
what we've been up to the reason a lot
of people are upset is because Marvel
probably isn't going to post that
publicly and they're probably gonna auto
ban anyone that posts it
the only reason like the James Gunn said
the big reason for that was because the
effects aren't finished so Marvel feels
like it won't hold up to repeated
viewings like it's really fun to see it
once
but you know typically with new footage
like this you watch it like five or six
times they just feel like they want to
wait till they have something nice and
shiny that looks completely finished
before they post it officially so
depending on what actually ends up
happening next week I'll totally do a
video for it whatever the trailer is of
course I'm gonna do a video for it but
with things like that that are kind of
up in there you just kind of have to
wait and see what its gonna look like
but one way or another there will be
footage next week so it's gonna be a lot
of fun in the movies gonna be great I
don't know why Marvel is worried about
people seeing unfinished footage I feel
like there's just like a lot of people
who aren't really connected to what's
going on they haven't been following the
movie so they see half-finished footage
or footage without the effects or music
layed in and they think that's what the
final movie looks like I know that
sounds kind of stupid but you'd be
surprised what the average person thinks
like when they see something offhandedly
but no worries it'll be awesome and
that's actually the only thing that I
think is gonna be somewhat problematic
there'll be a whole bunch of trailers
pretty much all the other movies that
are going like Doctor Strange I think
that they'll be posting official footage
so no worries about that stuff so
they'll probably be some new Doctor
Strange footage they'll be guardians of
the galaxy there'll be new Suicide Squad
and then there'll be like flash season 3
there'll be a whole bunch of other stuff
I'll be doing preview videos next week
that'll be a little more specific about
when stuff is dropping the videos I'm
going to do so be sure to subscribe to
get that and I'll just go ahead and
start my Marvel giveaway early so all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
I'll just remind everyone the next
Marvel video I post tomorrow I've got
some new Star Wars Episode 8 coming so a
lot of new comic book stuff coming this
weekend a lot of Star Wars Star Wars
Celebration is still happening right now
it's gonna be going all weekend so
there'll be a whole bunch of new Star
Wars stuff while you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here
for my breakdown of the new Star Wars
rogue one footage and you can click here
for my Thor Ragnarok teaser video thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys time